a look now at an iconic car that has a
huge following car tester Christophe
Bauer is out and about and a Volkswagen
Beetle convertible exploring the
mountain plateau of Lavar Oni in Italy
the beetle Cabriolet was manufactured
right up until 1980 it was first
designed back before the Second World
War
Christoph says these days the
convertible is the epitome of freedom
and independence but in the 1930s things
were different those who could afford it
but a hardtop sedan preferably with a
chauffeur there were always soft tops
but they tended to be very basic and
quite a bit cheaper so the beetle which
was always intended as a car for the
masses obviously planned to have a
convertible right from the start
fun fun and Kaba yoga plant at it
the first prototype for the soft-top
beetle was built in 1936
although series production would not
follow for many years after the war it
was the hardtop models of the first
Volkswagen that rolled off the assembly
lines in Wolfsburg in 1949
finally the Beetle Cabriolet took to the
road dusty McMahon had many were keen to
get in on the action
like the first 60 VW sedans the pre-war
soft top prototype was built in the
garage of Ferdinand Porsches villa in
Stuttgart at Basel for the Beetle
Cabriolet was always based on the most
expensive and powerful version of the
Beetle sedan that was currently
available this model from 1979 for
example has the 1.6 liter engine from
the VW 1303 s which was first
manufactured in 1972 and was the most
powerful beetle engine ever to go into
series production it goes from 0 to 100
kilometers in 20 seconds
yeah nothing to get excited about there
but focusing on power and speed was
always a taboo for VW their priority was
reliability
that's a shame a little more power would
certainly suit the 1303 convertible the
1979 Super Beetle as it's known had the
best beetle suspension of all time
distinguished by a coil spring and strut
front suspension this car that is more
than 40 years old and with a pre-war
design takes bends with astonishing and
astounding ease either crystal says the
handling of the VW Beetle is very
special the steering is unbelievably
responsive effortless because the engine
is at the back it powers the rear axles
in the wheels directly providing endless
traction as Porsche fans know this
design setup can actually handle a lot
more horsepower in fact the Porsche 924
that was designed together with VW drew
on the beetle design now that has to be
the ultimate accolade for the beetle
suspension stock for this k5 five acres
the modern chassis that was introduced
to the VW 1302 in 1970 allows for more
space in the trunk thanks to the longer
front from 1970 to the 1303 came with a
taller curved windshield to comply with
US law which required a greater distance
between the driver and the windscreen
the modern style padded dashboard was
another concession to passive safety at
the rear an air-cooled 1.6 liter boxer
engine provides 50 horsepower
isogai noise at the exterior of the 1303
convertible reveals little technical
progress there are a few details like
the chunky taillights that earned the
nickname elephant's feet but otherwise
the basic shape of the VW Beetle hardly
changed in 30 years of production but in
the interior there were big changes
introduced in the 1970s plastic
everywhere in those days that was
state-of-the-art of course but today
you'd love to just have a little chrome
here and there instead but the robust
soft top design was retained the roof
can be shut and a few simple steps
keeping out that summer rain simple and
practical right from the start the
soft-top version of the beetle cost
around 1/3 more than the sedan still
sales for the Cabriolet boom for over
three decades
christoph says four seater convertibles
have a long-standing tradition in
automotive history but in the 1970s they
were a dying breed with just two models
left the VW Cabriolet which sold for
$14,000 and the rolls-royce Corniche
convertible for $180,000 so you can
guess which model ensured the
four-seater convertible survived
rolls-royce sold 3,000 cars in total
while VW sold 20,000 convertibles a year
fahncy thousand Paul Yong
after more than 20 years of production
the Beetle Cabriolet finally reached its
zenith in the 1303 robust reliable
equipped with a modern suspension and
capable of a top speed of 130 km/h and
yet the Beatles days were numbered
dhanyavad for years the soft-top beetle
was considered the world's best-selling
convertible during 31 years of
production over 330 thousand vehicles
rolled off the assembly lines only in
1991 was it overtaken by the VW Golf
when it was announced in 1978 that
production of the Beetle Cabriolet was
to end fans stormed the VW dealers to
snap up the last remaining cars which is
pretty rare in the fast-moving
automotive industry so the VW
convertible is definitely a milestone in
automotive history driving with the wind
in your hair the Beetle Cabriolet proved
convertibles don't have to be an
unaffordable luxury and in so doing has
guaranteed that the soft-top
lives on
you